hi this is presto occur in this video
IVA riddle for you alright I'm somewhere
on earth I walk one mile south one mile
west and one mile north I end up exactly
back where I started where am i this
puzzle has a long history in the tech
industry Microsoft would famously ask it
as one of its technical brain teasers
Elon Musk who co-founded PayPal and
Tesla Motors also admits this is one of
his favorite riddles so can you figure
it out where did I start after I walk
one mile south one mile west and one
mile north and ended up exactly back
where I started
first of all I should tell you there is
a solution in fact there is more than
one spot that's a huge hint I'm gonna
give you so give this puzzle a try
when you're ready continue watching the
video and I'll explain what the solution
is
all right so let's imagine the earth as
a perfect sphere one spot that's the
answer is the North Pole if you're
starting at the North Pole when you go
one mile south then one mile west and
finally one mile north you will go on a
triangular path and end up exactly back
at the North Pole so this is one answer
to the puzzle and this is what most
people think about in fact there are
many more answers to this puzzle so
let's think about our perfectly
spherical earth now let's think about
some places near the South Pole imagine
a circle that is exactly one mile around
in circumference and we're going to have
this really close to the South Pole so
this is not drawn to scale obviously but
think about a circle that's exactly one
mile around very near the south
pull we'll call that circle c1 now
imagine starting exactly one mile north
of this circle so what would happen when
you go one mile south you're going to go
from your starting point to the circle
c1 when you go one mile west you're
going to go exactly one mile around the
circle and come back to your starting
point on that circle and finally when
you go one mile north you're going to
end up back at your starting point so
this is another type of solution to this
puzzle you start one mile north of c1
you'll go down to c1 one mile south then
you'll travel around that circle and
then you'll go back up exactly to your
starting point in fact there's an entire
circle this entire circle that's one
mile north of c1 is all a set of
possible answers so this is an infinite
number of infinite number of points that
you could start it that are one mile
north of c1 so we already know that
north pole is an answer this is an
infinite number of answers that you can
also add but the puzzle gets more
interesting now let's consider a circle
that's exactly 1/2 mile around so it's
going to be very near the South Pole and
it's exactly 1/2 mile around in
circumference we can think about exactly
the same solution if we are one mile
north of this circle see 1/2 we will go
one mile south to the circle now when we
go one mile west we're going to traverse
this circle exactly two times and then
we're going to go one mile north and end
up back at the starting point so think
about how this works you go one mile
south towards C 1/2 then when you go one
mile west you're going to go around the
circle two times and then you're going
to return one mile north exactly to
where you started and once again there
are an infinite number of these points
because
you can be anywhere along the circle
that's one mile north of C 1/2 so you
could start anywhere that's one mile
north of C 1/2 and that's another
infinite set of solutions we can
generalize this let's think about a
circle that's 1 over n miles around and
we want n to be a whole number so we
have 1/3 1/4 etc if you start 1 mile
north of C 1 over N you're going to go
one mile south to that circle then
you're going to go around that circle n
times because the circle has a
circumference of 1 over n and then
you're going to go one mile north and
end up exactly where you started once
again there's an infinite number of
solutions here because you can start
anywhere along the circle that's one
mile north of c1 over N so got it you
can start anywhere that's one mile north
of c1 over N where n is an integer and
that's the complete set of solutions one
answer is you could be at the North Pole
you'll trace out a triangular path
another set of solutions is you can be
one mile north of c1 so this is a circle
that's exactly one mile in circumference
and you can be anywhere on the circle
that's one mile north of it that's an
infinite number of spots you could also
be one mile north of c1 over two so
that's a circle with a circumference of
1 over 2 this is another infinite set of
solutions and you could really do this
for C one mile north of C 1 over n and
of course this 1 over n can be true for
any positive integer n so you can be any
one mile north of C 1 over n C 1 over n
has an infinite number solutions and one
mile north of it there's also an
infinite number of spots that you can
start from so the answer to this puzzle
is there's one plus infinity times
infinity so it's a really cool
brain teaser you can ask it to people
and almost no one gets to answer correct
I hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can also catch me on social
media at pressure Locker on a bunch of
sites I've listed links in the
description and please check out my
books if you like this puzzle I've
written several books about math puzzles
there's a link to all my books in the
video description thanks for watching